foreign
North and talk to Bailey in Toronto
what's up Bailey
hey Dr John how are you thanks for
taking my call of course I tried my best
about but it sounded terrible can you
give me one
hey there we go perfect what's up how
can I help
so this is my question
um in my relationship why do I feel like
I have to get mad for any change to
occur I feel like this speaks more about
me than him like I am not confident
enough to speak up before things
escalate why do we wait for emotions to
boil over to talk about issues things
change how do we learn to voice our
needs before things get out of control
how do we create a relationship where
both parties feel safe to be vulnerable
about their needs wants more
specifically
what happened to us I need awesome I got
117 questions let's go all right let's
do it what what tools that you need for
what
to learn to regulate my emotions okay
and how do I learn to respond instead of
react and then how can I work on my
delivery
so it's a lot it's a lot well it's a lot
but it's it's just it's two simple sides
of a coin okay
and usually um if you ever listen to the
show very much you hear me talk about
the dance that couples get into
um my guess is it's one of two things
number one
you feel so uncomfortable saying what
you need
I don't like this in bed when you do
this I need you to be home between 5 30
and 6 because I make dinner and our kids
need to go to bed I don't like it when
your mom calls and starts telling me
what to do or whatever
and it's so hard for you to say those
things that you almost have to not
almost you do you have to
boil the water so hot that the steam
pushes the lid off the top that's one
that's one Avenue
the other Avenue is you constantly
constantly
tell your husband what you need what you
want what you like and he doesn't give a
crap
and the only way he will do anything is
if you run up and grab him by the ears
and shake his head row and yell real
loud
and maybe a little bit of both
so if I put those two on the table which
one feels more natural
over and get angry I think it's like an
attention thing
it's like I don't want to be then I
don't want to be labeled the needy wife
or girlfriend so what if what if you
switch and he'll pay attention to me
what what if you switched it it gave him
the keys to the kingdom
what like somebody told you that your
needs made you annoying
for most men that I talk to they dream
of their girlfriends or their wives
telling them what they need
so that they can love them better they
don't know how
okay but somebody told somebody told you
needs were you being a whiny like
annoying girlfriend or a whiny annoying
wife
instead of needs being a really clear
road map for how your husband can love
you really amazingly right now
okay that's that's reframing it for sure
so give me an example of something you
don't like to say
or when's it let me say this you called
because of something did you get really
mad and then you got frustrated with
yourself for getting so mad
we like I don't know I don't know I'm
I'm just like
what's the last time you were frustrated
um
like over the weekend but this is simple
stuff like I get frustrated because in
our day today I don't have enough time
to walk the dog do my exercise see my
family meal prep you know what I mean
like it's just frustrating that we don't
have enough time to do these normal
things
so then hold on hold on there and you've
created a picture all by yourself of
what normal is of what quote unquote's
supposed to do looks like oh well that's
what I would like to get done in a day
okay
where does that picture come from
take my routine
and what's that routine keep you safe
from
lean on that routine like people have
sat with lean on cocaine
because without that list you feel
untethered and that your world is going
to unspool underneath you
punishments
but you don't like productivity and
accomplishments for the sake of
productivity and accomplishments you
like productivity and accomplishments
because it keeps you from having to feel
why
oh my gosh I don't know
most of the time it distills all the way
down into two things either I don't like
the life I've created for myself or more
terrifyingly I don't like me
yeah I mean there's some insecurity for
sure
that's there why are you insecure with
the guy that looked you in the eye and
said
until the end of time and Beyond I do
I'm confident with his loyalty
but you're not confident with his love
why
because
he didn't stand up for me on on an
occasion we had a we had a grenade
thrown into our living room and now it
was a terrible position for any for like
a father to put a son in I can go in the
background if you want
but here's what here's what's instructed
so is your father-in-law said something
awful about you and he didn't stick up
for you
the father-in-law moved
in and then
um my significant other was like working
away from home so it was just me and the
father-in-law and we weren't getting
along and I ended up leaving the house
um and yes like my partner never stuck
up for me so I just again I put that GPS
pin in like my body is unsafe here like
it's just hard to trust again it is even
though he's kept showing up I know I'm
just wary but that means you've you've
held you're holding on to that did he
apologize yeah I know laughs
sort of okay then no
then he has it and so you see what I
mean there's a there's a the dance that
happens
you're mad at him about something that
happened a long time ago
and
he in his mind thinks that he solved
that
yeah it would probably be shocked if he
knew that that was still lingering that
was still on his kitchen table this
morning or this weekend
and
you are confident in his loyalty but you
are not confident that he'll show up for
you or that he'll love you
and so you can see that you're walking
through your own life with no Foundation
you'd never know where the next step is
going to go because you hang on to these
things or you don't hang on to him in in
a negative way you don't deal with them
and so my question for you would be
what would it look like tonight to take
him to dinner and say I'm going to tell
you something's kind of nuts
but I'm still can find myself so mad
about that thing that happened with your
dad
and I feel like you never apologize for
me and I know it sounds bananas but I
still hang on to that
and it's hard for me to trust you
that you'll be there for me again
what if you did that
in a non-angry non-raged out non-winy
complaining way but just a
I'm freaking Bailey and I'm allowed to
have feelings and this is what they are
right now
what would that be like
I think that would be a good
conversation to have
why can't why couldn't you do that
um well we we both work for a utility
and we both work on the road so we we're
away from each other during the week and
then only see each other on weekends
but we could talk over the phone it's
not a big deal no don't do it over the
phone it's gotta be in person it's gotta
be in person
yeah but we have talked about it
um
and I I don't know again it's like the
tools I don't have the tools how do I
get over this
you know do you just do it do you just
forget about it no
you look at somebody if he reaches
across the table and grabs your hands
and says listen I'll let you down I'm so
sorry it will never happen again
and then you say thank you
I'm really grateful and then if that
moment if you choose I'm going to choose
to believe you I'm going to choose to
trust
then from that point forward every time
that story pops into your head you
literally say out loud no not doing that
but you don't because
hell hang on a second
you replay those stories because they
make you feel powerful and they make you
feel right
and they make you feel like you are the
one done the injustice
right and then your identity over time
becomes
the worst things that ever happened to
you
and that's a miserable place to build an
identity
right
yes and so you find yourself getting mad
all the time because you don't like the
guy that you're with
and then you find yourself getting mad
all the time because you don't like the
fact that you've stayed with a guy that
you don't like
I do like them I know he is a good man
except for the fact they want to get
over this stuff
but I don't think you do yet
or let me say it this way okay you want
to want to get over it
but it provides you something what is it
giving you what's it giving you
it's giving me nothing because it's
giving me like anger which then I yell
at him and then he shuts down and then
that's why what is anger getting oh this
phone call what does anger give you it
gives me the attention for like a brief
moment nothing gets a call
it gives you power oh
oh okay it gives you right
and somewhere along the way
power became a thing that made your body
the thing like made your body be able to
stand up a little bit taller
and what most relationships need is less
power and more taking a knee I love you
enough to tell you what I need
I love me to tell you enough like what I
need
and then I'm gonna fight and scratch and
Claw with my body as it tries to send
signals again oh remember last time I
remember last time nope not doing that
anymore I'm gonna lean in closer
here's going to give you a good example
like this is kind of putting my dirty
laundry out there but
um
my wife I got frustrated with something
yesterday
I caught myself
and I went outside
and by the way I was acting like a baby
also don't think this is anything great
and Noble I went outside
and I got the Armor All in a rag and I
cleaned my wife's car
and I threw away all the trash and she's
got two kids that she's traveling I mean
our two kids that she travels all over
the place with it was full of all kind I
cleaned the car and then I took it and
went and picked my son up and then we
went and got her gas
and I intentionally got the expense of
gas I don't even know why just made me
feel like I'm giving her the best I can
so that she came in today got out in her
car and it was clean it was all arm
rolled up and
it was full of gas for the week
and by the time I got done
my little hissy fit whiny baby-ness was
completely gone
and it's because I took a knee
I chose service instead of power I chose
service instead of being right
and I couldn't think my way there I had
to go act I had to go do something nice
see what I'm saying
like you have to make a choice I don't
want to carry this crap anymore
but that is going to leave you feeling
exposed as exposed as the day you left
that house because your husband wouldn't
intervene with his dad
and that's the path
okay
you're like wow that sucks
no I mean I I just it's like what are
like what are practical actions in the
moment right in the moment walk away
walk away in the moment or before the
moment by the way if you get to the
moment it's too late
yeah so you all come up with it with a
hand sign
or some sort of phrase a safe word if
you will
and when you find yourself getting
enraged you say take five and you walk
away
and if you all have gone to lunch or
breakfast and on a Saturday morning when
you're actually together and you say
I'm trying to break this habit of
getting mad and every time I feel like I
need to tell you my needs I remember
this all the stuff from our past and so
I just get angry and I'm trying to stop
that so In the Heat of the Moment I'm
gonna raise my hand and just like do a
number like make a five
or I'm going to fist bump you and when I
do that don't take that as rejection
take that as me getting overwhelmed and
me they can control back over my
emotions
also journaling every single day of your
life that sounds all woo-woo but what it
serves is a pressure release valve
you let it build and you let it build
you let it build and then you explode
the third thing is is a weekly every
Sunday night or Saturday night y'all
have 15 or 20 minutes to go over
calendar go over your budget and look
each other in the eye and say how can I
love you this week
and if you do those all these things up
River
then when something blows up it's not
there to come out
does that make sense
yes you're like yeah I've asked for
check-ins I've asked for check-ins
and you're not getting them I've gotten
a wave
I mean
um well
worth starting we're working on it
um the journaling I've I've gotten away
from and I want to start again
and okay uh Bailey when you listen to
this callback I want you to pay
attention to one important thing
you have completely divorced yourself
from yourself
journaling didn't just escape from you
you quit doing it
yeah yeah that's right being angry every
time you feel like you need to say
something isn't your body
um isn't like a demon landing on your
shoulder you'd get mad and you feel
powerful in that anger and you keep it
for a second
you ask your husband for something and
he just looks at you and goes I'm not
doing that and you have to live in that
guilt and in that grief that your
partner won't join you and something
that you have said is important
right
you have to get back to I I own how I
feel I own the things that I do and I'm
not going to Outsource these to other
people
and for everybody listening if you wait
until the moment to come up with an
anger exercise it's way too late
way too late anger points Us in the
direction of something we care about and
my guess Bailey is that you care so much
about this marriage and there's probably
just because I've done this a long time
I may be wrong
there's probably some stuff that is on
the table that is deeper seeded here
with you and your husband
which conversations that you need to
have that you haven't had yet
maybe it's about work maybe it's about
Fidelity maybe it's about your romantic
relationship maybe it's about kids maybe
it's about any number of things maybe
it's about all the way back to that
situation with his family
when it came down to it you weren't
there for me maybe that's it
but your body is telling you every time
you need something he's not gonna be
there and that's where you got to
address it the anger is your body trying
to get your attention
and that's a good thing
so trying to duct tape over that is not
helpful going way Upstream so that you
get the things that your body needs like
connection like connectivity like being
on the same page like a unified purpose
like romance and intimacy all those
things Upstream so that Financial
Security so that
when you need to say your needs out loud
you just say your needs out loud
but that's that's ownership of your
actions that's ownership of what comes
next it's you writing down in a journal
here's what I need
and I'm just going to practice it and
when I feel myself getting mad whoop
stop I'm gonna take a break because I'm
getting mad you're not doing anything
I'm choosing to get mad my body's
choosing anger and I don't know why but
it is and so I'm gonna take a break till
I come back and then we'll start over
again well then we'll start over again
you gotta practice it
but anybody telling you on the internet
some sort of snake oil salesman telling
you this is the five steps to feel
stupid it's dumb
you're talking about reimagining your
marriage
and getting as far up River as you can